[Music]
the idea of kind of deconstructing the
database has been a project that's been
happening maybe over the last ten years
or so the you know the Hadoop revolution
was in part about that and this talk is
kind of this isn't about any particular
database system I will be talking about
calcite from time to time but really
it's a talk about the kind of the laws
of physics that determine what makes a
good data system and some of the tricks
that are being used really since the
very first days of databases and how we
can apply those to you know the next
generation of systems and if you're not
writing your database which I expect
most of you are not writing your
database it's useful to know these
things simply to just to evaluate
whether this is a sound data
architecture so I hope that it's useful
for people that are doing data
engineering and not necessarily building
their own database management systems so
yeah quick intro to me I do a lot of
open-source work with the Apache
Software Foundation in part because
that's where a lot of interesting Big
Data stuff is happening I've been doing
open source for a very long time going
back to I built the Mondrian OLAP engine
which is the first open source or lap
engine back in 2001 and yeah contributed
to a variety of projects but the main
one I'm involved with is Apache calcite
more about that later I just I was at
Hortonworks until recently and a month
ago I joined Luca so not much of this
talk is going to be about looker because
I'm still learning about the company but
just a couple of things I wanted to say
about it first of all is everyone seems
to love looker
you know I the reason I joined look it
was because I met various people that
were customers of the company and they
loved it and the employees the the work
environment is extremely respectful
which is important to me and everyone is
you know functioning as a team and what
look it is the quick description of it
is a business intelligence tool but what
they're trying to do is create is to
create a data culture and a company
which means making it easy for the
business users to get hold of the data
that they that they want without writing
sequel or without bothering IT but the
way you achieve that is to basically to
provide this data model and they have a
language called look ml which is a human
readable and human writable it's it's
code you you you write your business
model in code and then deploy that and
everyone in the company is basically
seeing the same definition of all of the
measures and dimensions that they're
using so and the fact that it's code is
I've worked in bi a long time the fact
that it's code as opposed to a blob of
data in a repository is a very big deal
because it means you can put it in get
you can dip it you can push that patches
you can do all the things you do with
source code so bringing some of that
software engineering approach to
business intelligence I think is huge so
that's why I joined Lucca you can
surmise some of the ideas that I'm doing
in this talk I am hoping to bring into
looking over the next few months okay
so as to kind of motivate this here is a
so called simple query there's no
database management system involved and
the reason is because this is I'm kind
of thinking about the laws of physics
here imagine if you have the 2010 US
Census and 100 million household records
and each record is a kilobyte so you've
got 100 gigabytes of data and you
basically want to sum up that data
the goal is to sum up all the data in
five seconds
and the data stored on four disks and
the disks have sata3 through port the
short answer is it's impossible to
achieve the goal the reason is because
the disks you know a hundred gigabytes
of data one gigabyte per second it's
going to take a hundred seconds of disk
activity to pull the data off those
disks and yet we all query data systems
that are much bigger than that on a
daily basis so you know how do they do
it what is the trick so there's a
variety of solutions and all of these
all of these solutions are implemented
to some degree in your favorite database
management system the simple solution is
a sequential scan and it takes obviously
a hundred seconds if you paralyze the
query if you have if you've spread the
data over 40 discs then you still have
to kind of coordinate the data and bring
it back again the query takes maybe ten
seconds because you've you've basically
just got more i/o
capacity the kind of that so this is the
you know that that's the that's the fast
in my talk title caching the data if you
execute the query once and you cache the
query result or you cache all of the
data in memory if you happen to have a
hundred gigabytes of memory you cache
the results and then you you know you
can answer the question much more
quickly but the absolute fastest way
that you can compute the answer to this
is to materialize it in the words in
other words cheat pre compute the result
store the result
and when someone when someone asks that
question how many households are there
in the US you can basically in one
millisecond you can basically answer
that question so and that that is the
the you know that is the reality that's
the dirty truth that all database
management systems basically cheat they
don't answer the question you ask they
answer some similar question they pre
computed so I
I use the word materialized there I'm
gonna be talking a lot about
materialized views or materialized
queries so don't be put off by that
terminology but as I'll explain this
materialized queries is a pattern which
has existed a very long time and in
database management systems way before
the Oracle got the create materialized
view command in probably nineteen you
know we're all probably 2003 and even
better
sometimes you can't anticipate all of
the questions that people might ask that
the the very best solution is to
materialized cache the results and adapt
so if people start asking questions
they've never asked before start
building new materializations to answer
the question that they may ask in ten
minutes time so yeah lazy beat smart and
fast lazy meaning pre compute the
answers in advance so you just know the
answer so yeah here are some of the
questions I'm going to answer this talk
answer in this talk how do you tune a
data system or how should the data
system tune itself because you just
don't the data system on the day that
you load the first data set is not going
to be perfect because it doesn't know
what the query load is going to be and
so forth how did we implement this in
the Patrick owl site I'll explain a
little bit about what Apache calcite is
and and the the features that you would
use if you're building a database
management system how what are some of
the techniques you can use to organize
data and how to make the system
self-organizing so how can we bring in
techniques kind of like the term self
driving database has been used this idea
of systems that learn and adapt
automatically we're gonna be using a lot
of I'm well I think in terms of
relational algebra I think I dream in
relational algebra
relational algebra is what is underneath
every sequel system you use and probably
a lot of the no sequel systems as well
it's based on it's based on set theory
and a small number of basic operators
like
project and filter filters like the
where Clause aggregators like the group
by clause in a sequel statement and it
turns out using 8 or 10 of these core
operators you can represent a kind of
data flow graph which is logically the
question that you're asking for and
building a relational building
relational algebra is complicated
because you need to you need to build a
query optimizer and things like
statistics in order to execute a query
based on relational algebra that's the
that's the kind of bad news but the good
news is that once you've built a query
optimizer and you've built relational
algebra you can kind of start doing a
lot of really exciting things like well
what the database folks call data
independence which is now your
application is no longer dependent on
the way that your data is physically
stored on disk so you could for example
load your data kind of so it's scattered
randomly or throughout your disks and
then you notice you're doing a lot of
joins on product ID so you could
reorganize your data so it's partitioned
on product ID so product based joins are
now gonna run really fast if you've
built your data using cysts using sequel
or in fact anything with a query
optimizer you can reorganize your data
and your application doesn't have to
know about it at all if you build your
if you haven't done that and you've
organized your data into files then
you're going to have to completely
rewrite your application if you
reorganize the data like that and so
partitioning is just one of you know are
a hundred different techniques you can
use to reorganize your data to make the
queries run faster and also I'm not
really going to talk about query
optimization but you know a query
optimizer can achieve you know stunning
you know thousandfold improvements in
the in the performance of queries so
calcite is a it's an Apache top-level
project not many people have heard of it
actually who's heard of Apache calcite
before ok so about a third of the room
well that's good that's good because
it's not an end-user tool at all you
know it it probably only has 100
customers in the whole world people
people who are writing database
management systems are the people that
want to use calcite so if you're using
hive or flink or map D or Apache beam
sequel or Phoenix then you're using
calcite under the covers anyway it makes
a lot of good things possible we use the
Apache community development model which
means we're not dominated by any one
vendor we have people form from
competing companies all working together
under the Apache process and they all
basically put on their Apache hat which
means they are working for the good of
the project and leaving their particular
employers interests at the door and they
resulted with is we've created this
really useful thing that keeps on
getting better and if you want to get
involved that doesn't mean writing code
if you just want to talk to us ask
questions and join the the dev list the
email list and we'd be happy to help so
there's lots of ways of organizing data
there's lots of dimensions you can use
to organize data data format is just one
of them right whether you store your
data in orc or parque and if you just
store the data raw or indoor
column-oriented but there's a class of
organizations of data which I call
logical organizations which is if you
know that the data is if you know that
data from 2016 is over there in 2017 is
over there those kinds of organizations
of the data enable some kind of massive
performance improvements because the
system actually knows something kind of
about the semantics of the data and it
can turn a query on a billion rows to
what is really a query on a thousand
rows in other words it allows the
optimizer to rewrite the question in
terms of it makes it into a simpler
question so a lot of the stuff I'm going
to be talking about I'd call logical
optimizations or logical reorganizations
of the data lossy copies of the data
is actually one that's really
interesting it was I was talking to
someone today about Vertica which is a
kind of the first mainstream
column-oriented database came out in the
early 2000s and when you load it ate it
in a table in vertigo it will create you
might have columns
you know ABC X Y Z it will create one
projection of the data on maybe columns
a BZ and another projection on columns B
and C and so and it will just choose
which of the projections most closely
answers your query those kinds of things
where it's producing multiple copies of
the data in different sort orders is a
very powerful thing so the first kind of
materialized view the one that everyone
knows is the B tree index and so one of
the things I learned when I joined years
ago I work for the case of the kernel
development team in Oracle and I was
surprised to learn that in index in
Oracle is just a table it doesn't appear
in the catalog as a table but it's
structured just like a table and in fact
so when I created index you know I've
got an employee table with employee
number and name and department number if
I created an index on Department number
and name then it creates a table with
Department number name and r ID and that
table is physically sorted on Department
number I mean it creates a b-tree
structure above it but the the actual
records in a sorted on Department number
so it kind of has the same data as the
table and if I want to like look up all
employees in Department 20 it's kind of
like a joint I first of all find the
department 20 I find the Rorie's of the
records in the department number 20 and
then I go to the the actual table and
get those righties and that's kind of a
joint on row ID so an index is yeah it's
a redundant copy of the data as
evidenced by the fact you can say drop
index and create index and you get it
gets the data back again you can
recreate the contents of the index from
the contents of the table and it
accelerates queries if you say just you
know select count distinct Department
number it can more easily do that from
the index because the department numbers
are saw
it than going to the table so yeah it
accelerates a bunch of queries that you
wouldn't even think of as index queries
so the next thing is a covering index so
let's suppose we take that same index
and rather than storing row IDs we store
the employee number so now we've got the
same number of columns in the index as
we have the table in other words this
really is just it's a copy of the table
just in a different sort order now we
don't need their IDs anymore which is
good news because analytic databases
don't handle row ID lookups you know a
variety lookup is a random access to
something which is three server rooms
over and it's a very expensive roundtrip
so analytic databases don't even bother
with with row IDs so now we've basically
just got two copies of the tip of the
table and when someone sends a query we
could just choose a or b whichever one
is more suitable for that particular
query in fact you could say which table
is actually you know the primary copy
you could say well the one sorted on
Department number is the primary copy
and the other one is a redundant copy
there's the same information content in
both now if I'm writing a query
optimizer how do I tell the optimizer
this thing exists that's kind of the
what motivated me to add this kind of
stuff into calcite you know I didn't
want to write covering index support
into calcite I wanted to build some kind
of theory that allows me to model these
redundant copies of data and that thing
is something I call a materialized query
I hope you're beginning to see a pattern
here that's given another example which
is a bit further away or I preempted
myself so here's a materialized view
with literally the create the
materialized view DDL and in Oracle or
other systems that support these I'm
saying here's the table here's a query
the contents of the table are always the
same as the contents of the query and
the most important thing is I can write
the I don't have to reference that table
the mSpy depth no I don't have to
reference that in the query if I do a
query which can be satisfied by this
if I write a query that can be satisfied
by that relational expression it will
use the materialized view transparently
without without mean needing to do
anything so this is exactly the same as
that covering index on the previous
slide but the interesting thing is that
sequel in the metric crate materialized
view can be something very complex it
can be joins group bys exists unions or
all kinds of things here's another case
where a materialized views help let's
suppose who's used a spatial or
geospatial system ok probably used post
juice or something post just was a huge
amount of effort to develop adding
geospatial support into an existing
relational database there have been some
there's been some research done have had
how do I add spatial support to a date
and and sorry to backtrack the reason
why it's so difficult is spatial data is
difficult to deal with using the same
usually with relational data you there's
two ways of accessing the data you
either do access it by range so
everything between you know department
numbers between 100 and 200 or you
access it by hash code so all Department
numbers that hash to 7 spatial data you
can't use either of those techniques you
can't develop 1 dimensional range range
scan and you can't hash so you have to
add these dedicated spatial data
structures and that's what they did in
post yes and it was an awful lot of work
but there's a trick to add
spatial support to databases without
altering the underlying storage
structures of the database which I'm
about to show you and we're thinking
about this query so we've got a bunch of
restaurants in two-dimensional space and
we're interested in restaurants that are
within
let me see two squares of that yellow
circle and them in the top right-hand
corner a 1.5 just within 1.5 a distance
of 1.5 from the coordinate 6 comma 7 so
the trick is to convert this
two-dimensional space which is the
latitude and longitude coordinates into
a one dimensional space but we still
want to the trick is to ensure that if
two points are close to each other in
two-dimensional space then they are
sorry then they are likely to be close
to each other in this 1 dimensional
space so a space-filling curve the
Hilbert curve is the most famous
space-filling curve but there are other
space-filling curves every point in this
two-dimensional space is reached once is
the this this curve travels through
every point exactly once so everything
has a coordinate every point on this
base has a coordinate on the one
dimensional curve and the the locality
thing is really important because I want
to be able to do our range scan on this
along this curve in order to be able to
find all those restaurants in that
particular area of the map it's not
always 1 range scan maybe so in some
cases you need to arrange scans or three
range scans but anyway you're still
accessing only a small proportion of the
of the curve and by the way I think I
think if it is the easiest way of
thinking about this is that is that the
the coordinates on the curve is a value
between 0 and 1
so the rather than going from 1 to 4
think of it as going from 0 to 0.25 to
0.5 to 1 so so how do we use this in a
materialized view what we do is we
compute a column we've got our
restaurants table with x and y we
compute a column H which is the distance
along this hilbert curve and so here on
the bottom right of the screen there it
is and then when I see this you know dis
less than 1.5 I actually changed the
query to convert this into a range scan
and the database that's storing this
let's suppose this is HBase HBase is you
know has tables which are sorted by a
particular key if that key is age then I
can very easily do a range scan on that
on that key and find all the restaurants
in that in that region there might be
some false positives there might be
things that are on the curve that are
slightly outside that 1.5 kilometer
radius but it works pretty well and
HBase is not a spatial database we're
just using this sorted table which is
the you know the main data structure of
HBase so this is pretty cool and so this
materialized view is not a new data
structure this materialized view is
simply a very small piece of knowledge
the optimizer has when the query is
coming in that says I can safely do this
rewrite with this query in terms of x
and y to use this age column so I think
this is a this is a pretty neat trick so
I think I covered a lot of this we tell
the optimizer we tell it about this H
column we tell it what expression is in
this column and then we put it in the
important part is we put it in a table
which is physically ordered on H and
then we can get a professional
efficiently execute the query another
area that's kind of close to my heart
another area of you know non-traditional
sequel is streaming queries streaming
queries are you know real time data is
ever more important and we need a
declarative way of dealing with
streaming queries in continuous ETL and
sequel is well sequels not a perfect
language for any application but turns
out streaming sequel is a pretty
effective way of defining continuous
continuous queries and I've been doing a
lot of work on this and an apache
working with projects like flink and
sums and beam so and one of the cool
things about using sequel for streaming
queries is
in a streaming database you are
sometimes interested in continuous
queries in other words tell me every
time there's an order over a thousand
units but I'm also interested in
historic queries how many orders larger
than a thousand units did I have between
1st of June and 31st of December that's
a historic query that's a database query
that's not a streaming query at all I'm
interested in both kinds of queries and
I'm also interested in hybrid queries so
give me an order which is larger than
the average size you know an order which
is larger than the average size of
orders average size of orders for that
particular product that's combining you
know streaming data that just arrived 2
milliseconds ago with data that's been
building up over the last year because
we're using sequel are actually able to
combine streaming query and historical
data so sequel helps us solve the first
part of the problem which is how do we
even Express this question it doesn't
help us answer the it doesn't help us
actually implement it so implementing
this is hard now what would we how do we
go ahead and implement this if we're
using say Kafka to represent our stream
the data that's that flowed a year ago
is long gone from Kafka so in order to
implement this we probably need
something like the system kind of needs
to know that data is flowing out of
Kafka and say flowing into park' files
that are managed by hive or something
and so when it receives this hybrid
query it has to know that today's data
or the last week of data is in Kafka and
the last 10 years of data is in hive and
form this query so
that that table of historic data is
essentially a materialized view it's the
the system knows where to find this bit
of data and where to find that bit of
data so a materialized view is a way of
telling the system where all the little
bits of data are and of course I'm a
query optimizer guy so I don't tend to
be very concerned with maintaining the
data maintaining the materialized views
that's someone else's job but that is a
big part of what the system does is
keeps that materialized view up-to-date
as data arrives so I've given you a you
know a list of three examples of things
that can be difficult data problems that
can be modeled by materialized views
that general idea of having a table and
a relational algebra expression that
says what's in that table is incredibly
powerful and I think I think it's a
pattern that we will start seeing over
and over and over again in the next 10
years of data management systems so how
long do I have left okay how do we
design these materialized views you know
simple answer is users can do it but
that's a very imperfect answer so what
we'd yeah the first answer is always
humans to in these systems the second
answer will be we would like the systems
to adapt maybe in fairly minor ways to
start with that get smarter over time so
the in imagine we have this recommender
write the input to this recommender
ideally would be the DML in other words
the definitions of the tables they've
created the queries that have that have
been seen historically and the
statistics in other words this seems to
be a primary key this this column seems
to have you know 20 unique values you
know all of that kind of stuff and this
so this recommender would see all of
this all of this data including queries
that are arriving in real time and say
hey I'm gonna I'm going to start
producing some
materialized views or I'm going to
reorganize this table I'm going to you
know repartition this table on product
ID because I'm seeing a lot of joins on
this and I mean there are simple forms
of adaptation that we don't even think
of as adaptations but simply a cache
isn't as a way of a building an adaptive
system right it's it's just I'm gonna
keep this data around because they just
read it two minutes ago there's a really
good chance they're going to use it in
the next 30 minutes that's what a cache
is so as the system gets systems get
smarter then perhaps we can start having
more forms of adaptation built into our
systems this is kind of where I'm
heading out you know thinking I've been
involved in BI systems analytic
databases for a long time this is kind
of my Holy Grail that I've been working
towards for probably the last 10 years
in memory materialized views so this
idea where the gray bar at the bottom is
the data on disk and the circle at the
top is this user that's you know sending
sending queries via tableau or whatever
whatever tool they're using and when
they hit a piece of data what it should
do is pull that pull that data into
memory such that as far as the tool is
concerned it's still it's still a sequel
data set that it can use but it's a it's
a piece of data in memory and over time
the system is going are they are
interested in analyzing data in Texas
and Arizona from 2014 ok I'm going to
start building some summaries for that
data in memory so they're you know the
queries over the next hour we're going
to get fast I did that the wrong way in
Mondrian I kind of built these caching
but I built it in Java hash tables which
were great that there's just no way you
can join a java hash table to a table in
Oracle so it just kind of right bit
wrong and then the probe these are the
kind of the I don't know research
problems we have to do we have to solve
you know the the human has to deal with
these problems but a the system is going
to have to deal with these problems in
the future
so figure out which materializations to
create populate them perhaps populate
them incrementally rewrite queries a
materialized view is kind of useless if
you have to reference it in your query
so when a query comes in you have to
recognize that this materialized view
could be used to answer that query and
then over time create new
materializations to adapt to the query
load and then lastly it needs to be
expressive so if you if you're dealing
we want to deal with an extended sequel
that can deal with streaming that can
deal with nested collections that can
deal with like machine learning complex
event processing kind of structures not
just select from where
so in calcite we introduced this data
structure called a lattice which is a
it's kind of a space of possible
materialization so we were focusing
initially on the on the problem of
summary tables if if you're if you're
dealing with a bi application then an
awful lot of the queries are select from
where join group by in other words they
join several tables together effect
table and dimension tables and then
aggregate on some combination of
attributes and a summary table is a very
useful form of materialization to create
because it saves you from reading a lot
of data and it doesn't occupy a lot of
space the summary table is often you
know thousands of times smaller than the
original data set so a lattice is kind
of telling the system of that the star
schema what are the dimensions and what
are the measures what are the what are
the join paths here and so once you've
created a lattice it will start the
system will start watching for queries
that are coming in and start thinking
about possible summary tables that could
create the problem is there's a lot of
possible summary tables so if you even
have 10 attributes
you know 10 10 columns for example 10
dimension columns then there's 2 to the
10 possible aggregate tables you could
create so as you can imagine and on this
on this diagram I've kind of diagrammed
out some of the each each of the
ellipses is a possible summary table the
one at the top is the grand total it
only has one row you've got a summary
table summing by zip code which has
43,000 records in it you've got one by
month which has 12 records the one by
year in month has 60 records because
we've got five years of worth of data
and so forth and then at the bottom is
the the raw data which is a million rows
so as you can see as you have more items
in your group by clause the the size of
the summary table gets larger as you
have fewer items in your group by clause
the summary table gets smaller but it
can answer fewer queries so yeah so
here's a typical set of summary tables
that we would that we would choose the
orange ones are the ones we've decided
to materialize and if you look at
virtually every query will hit one of
these if you come down from the top of
the of the graph virtually every query
will hit one of these and therefore
we'll be able to use that so if for
example I have a query on zip code
I will hit the summary table which is on
zip code state and gender which has
twice as many records approximately as
the zip code but that's fine I can
easily roll it up so there I'm going to
skip in the interest of time I'm going
to skip over the algorithm to generate
these
in fact I'm running so short of time I'm
probably gonna skip over a lot
oops there we go the algorithm to
generate these summary tables actually
is a voracious user of statistics so one
of the features we added into calcite
was data profiling an algorithm which
can basically do select count distinct X
select count distinct Y select discount
distinct X comma Y for every combination
of columns in your database and just
figure out which of your primary keys
which you know which you know product
color is functionally dependent on
product ad so it can discover these
functional relationships and therefore
figure out before it goes and builds
them what the size of these summary
tables is going to be and I'm going to
I'm going to skip over this but the long
story short the algorithm makes
extensive use of hyper log log as a way
of doing approximate counts to kind of
grok the contents of your database and
here's a kind of the the algorithm runs
iteratively it starts off by just
looking at single columns you know
select count distinct X select count
testing Y and then when it finds columns
that have unexpectedly high cardinality
it then tries combining them together
and it runs adaptively until it
basically is no longer surprised a
surprising combination is when state and
zipcode have fewer combinations together
than they would have individually which
basically tells you they are in
statistical terms they're not
independent variables so based on this
and if in a small number of iterations
the algorithm can basically come up with
a pretty good estimate of all of the
functional dependencies in a in a star
schema
so I am going to and there's another
feature in calcite which basically you
don't have to specify any business model
at all but can just observe the queries
coming in and noticing that you often
join the sales table to the customer
table and in another query you often
join the sales table to the product
table in the product class table and
therefore infers what your star schemas
are based on the incoming query load so
to summary to summarize materialized
views are yeah the one thing I want you
to take away is materialized views are
important and we're going to see a lot
of them and they enable not just
high-performance systems but the label
systems to learn from the query history
the query activity on the system and
relational algebra is well relational
algebra kicks ass so thank you so much
for your talk it's just so great to
place a face with a name I remember
installing Mondrian for the first time
back in like oh five and I was like oh
my god this guy's crazy he's giving away
sequel server analysis services for free
I know I know open-source people are we
might we find people to employ us yeah
my my question was in terms of I haven't
really looked under the covers at
calcite does it give any guidance in
terms of things like oh I'm pulling
things into memory cache therefore if
I'm on a cluster of query machines that
are providing the compute that I should
shard the cache like is there that kind
of okay yeah indirectly yes so calcite
as a query optimizer has statistics so
you should you know looking at a
particular query you can look at you
know but you can look at the statistics
of that query and figure out what its
memory utilization is
and if you're using more memory than
your cluster has then at least it can
tell you something is wrong calcite
doesn't provide that directly but
indirectly it is it's giving you the
tools to self cheer in the system I
think this is kind of the downside of
open source as we tend to produce tools
but we don't produce full product so
what I'm talking about here are some of
the tools in the toolbox that can be
used that that will be an excellent
product to build and calcite gives you
all of the raw materials to to do it I
mean you know a set of statistics that
can look at a piece of relational
algebra and tell you how much memory
we'll use is it's taken a lot of effort
to build that so you'd be building on
some you know very good foundations
question here so I'm curious what if
anything for your talk is are you plan
or hope to incorporate within Booker my
understandings look or sort of sits on
top of the data warehouse is agnostic -
a lot like the low level planner issues
that you talk about
yeah let's say some of the things I mean
one of the things I liked about looker
is it leans in common with Mondrian
actually it leans very heavily on the
data warehouse it doesn't try and do it
doesn't try and make itself into a data
processing engine so it generates some
very complex queries and sends them to
you know bigquery and redshift but I
still think I think there are some areas
where we are perhaps sending the same
query or very repetitive stuff to the to
the database over and over again so we
maybe can be a bit smarter about what we
send but I have no plans to radically
change the way look at works I think
just a little bit of intelligence and
how we generate queries could improve
things yeah we'll see my brother kind of
noticed that I seem to have kind of a
zigzag in my career you know I will I
will work for a bi company then work for
a database company and then work for a
bi company so I'm on the you know the bi
company in arrow so the work I'd done on
Mondrian motivated what I did in calcite
because I knew the databases were not
providing what I needed to build a fast
I tool now I'm on the bi tool phase and
so we can maybe leverage some of that
some of the stuff in calcite to be more
intelligent about what queries we send
to the database
you